what's your reaction to the naming of
jihadi John and also do you have answers
or will you be seeking answers from
security services as to why and how he
was allowed to slip through the net well
first of all I'm not going to talk about
specific individuals and specific cases
but I just make three points first of
all when there are people anywhere in
the world who commit appalling and
heinous crimes against British citizens
we will do everything we can with the
police with the security services with
all that we have at our disposal to find
these people and put them out of action
that is the number one priority for me
second point I work very closely with
our security services I meet with them
regularly I ask them searching questions
about what they do and in my almost five
years experience of Prime Minister I
think they are incredibly impressive
hard-working dedicated courageous and
effective at protecting our country all
of the time they're having to make
incredibly difficult judgments and I
think basically they make very good
judgments on our behalf and I think
while we're in the middle of this vast
effort to make sure British citizens are
safe and the most important thing is to
get behind them third point in our
country we do have proper ways of
calling security and intelligence
services to account and scrutinizing the
work that they do not leave through the
Intelligence and Security Committee in
the House of Commons in Parliament which
has been considerably strengthened in
this Parliament by this government with
additional resources so I'm satisfied we
have in place the right ways of
scrutinizing the work that these
extraordinary men and women do on our
behalf and all I can say is even in the
last few months their dedication and
work has saved us from plots on the
streets of the United Kingdom that could
have done immense damage and so I think
it is a moment to stand up and thank
them for the work they do on our behalf